I say it so many times with the me to
movement I'm still waiting for the guy
who gonna come out and say there is such
woman who argues me famous Hollywood
producer it was a Weinstein yeah
Weinstein and then the likes of him I
mean it just went from one it was a
domino oh you know started you know
coming out and this woman with Weinstein
she went to hang out with him he told
her hang out in his bedroom in his hotel
room if a Muslim father was Islam any
guy tells her coming up she knows that
it's forget about anything
she knows even if she trusts him
hundred-percent she knows Allah says
itself so what they want from you they
want you free in bed that's it you hear
that in the woman she's like pulling
down trying to cook you know she's
feeling was their nature if nature is
acting foot yeah a natural instinct and
this is not putting a woman down and
putting they don't know any better
they don't know any better so I walk
into the into the room to check him so
he looks at his when I said mom is this
dad he asked his mom is this data but
you shouldn't be alone with a woman in
the hotel room having dinner late at
night now these are to save this but
this was now let me ask you for one you
you you get pregnant he walks out and
you're the one stuck with a baby have
you ever questioned the place you work
why we have to wear a uniform no you
just do it you just do it you want to
make the moment I get paid and they they
are entitled for in this message to the
Muslim woman more than anybody when
Allah so it just tells you to cover to
protect you right don't be fooled by
what you see the shaking of the hands
you know not being along with the
opposite gender and there is no good
future in the Hellfire
yeah how long they gonna live how many I
asked those sisters how many times you
shook hands with men that made you
uncomfortable
right men we're men right we're men and
what holds us from acting like any other
men is Elise Allah yes well other than
Islam we will be just like everybody you
ready this woman who's wearing almost
nothing unlike her industry she has a
person her hand and that purse has stuff
that she doesn't want any
to see right and when she wants to open
it you might go to the bathroom well
your body is more precious than anything
in there yes there is a video I'm sure
you saw it on YouTube where they show a
woman walking in New York yes okay
she's like regular American and how many
before but what you hear Allah has no
talent
you're so precious that Allah wants to
protect you it's not me who want to put
the hedge up on you it's not your
husband who wants to put the head
it's Allah who as you you know fill
Islam is a Dean of prevention and that's
where we need to understand Dean of
prevents you're not the wearing hijab or
you're not just probably that you're an
evil person but I'm calling for you to
be better than what you are and when you
cover more I will respect you more God
was God wants them to respect you they
want to undress you
[Music]
[Applause]
the attack that people make on women you
explain this beautifully like oh yeah
okay if Islam is so fair why does the
Muslim woman get half of that of the
Muslim male and then you give an example
that's just in limited cases can you go
ahead and explain it no this is even
easier yeah and that's again we become
apologetic right we are at we we are we
become embarrassed a lot of Muslims when
they're when this thing brought up to a
point where a lot of them will say I
heard a lot people who pose themselves
as P of knowledge where they said this
is in the past it doesn't apply to it we
heard them right it's very simple when
we talk about a half-share or when chef
Roman compared against two shares for
the male this is an in one scenario in
the Quran right of inheritance where
Allah Azza WA JAL talks to the parents
concerning their children their
daughters and sons right so when a
father dies or a mother dies and there
is a son there their son or male
children and female children that is
where the situation is two shares for
the milk against one share for the so we
have to understand that but the people
who inherit are not only brother or sons
and daughters brothers inherit right or
just talk about the females sisters
inherit mothers inherit the
grandmother's inheritance some
situations wives inherits daughters
inherit when there is no brothers right
so if you look at all these scenarios in
in in the issue of inheritance you will
find 75 percent minimum 75 percent of
scenarios where the female will inherit
the same or more than them
so what are you talking about that
females inherit half of them in females
inherit half of them in who in one
situation when their sisters and
brothers right who are inheriting their
parents
that's where Alonso says she too shares
for the boy
1 share for the girl what 2 shares for
the son 1 share for the daughter right
but even with that right now this is one
situation and then compared the rest
even with that the the brothers when the
father dies who's in who's in charge we
said there initially the male is in
charge of the family he is the one who
should look after his sister's right so
who's in charge to take care of this
girl especially if they're little the
brother from where from his mind right
he becomes if so if a father dies and he
has boys and girls and the girls is
let's say underage and the boy is adult
right now their money becomes in his
responsibility where he needs to
maintain it and hold it for these girls
until they become adult where they
become entitled for it but not to spend
from it's his money that he gonna have
to use to take care of his sisters it's
him who has to go out and try to provide
for his family
so even if a lot though it gives little
money for the male over the female Allah
put more responsibility on the males to
take care of the female and that's again
they don't understand Islam has a
comprehensive religion Islam is not okay
half you get one you get 2 no no okay
you get one you get 2 but guess what I'm
giving you two because you have to take
care of the when we're giving one if we
understand this lamp in this way then we
will have no problem relating and again
just do it
talking about specifically for the
inheritance this is a scenario yeah you
know so if you if on one end the person
is getting less but they don't have to
pay phone bill medical bill this bill
that bill that bill but the other one
over here is got all these expenditures
they're gonna quickly run ours will
quickly run out more faster than the
other one right I mean is a common sense
religion you beautiful so what is your
take now your reaction
to people who say Oh Islam is so you
know holding back of the woman she can't
do so many different things you know
then the the shaking of the hands you
know not being alone with the opposite
gender and then now your reaction to
what's happening today with the key
famous Hollywood producer was at
Weinstein yeah Weinstein and then the
likes of him I mean it just went from
one it was abdominals oh you know
started you know coming out and then now
you have even the wall street and
they're putting actually these rules
that would almost be identical to what
the creator is telling that I'm doing
it's um what's your take on that shake
my cake is Alonso Edwards always
prevails at then and and people
acknowledge at the end that their
solutions is what Allah they will not
say it but from their actions and the
steps they decide to take they realize
that you know what I mean we realize
that this is what Islam says so you've
read this now that now they put in there
that you shouldn't be alone with a woman
in the hotel room having dinner late at
night now these are the sameness but
this is now let me ask you for one who
are they protecting the woman yeah it's
not protecting the woman and they put
they set all these rules because they
want to protect the woman they are what
they were because the woman is the one
being abused yes I say it so many times
with the me to movement I'm still
waiting for the guy who gonna come out
and say there is such woman who abused
me never so far nobody came to say a
woman abused me or sexually you know
it's always the woman is the victim so
when Allah has Odin and this message to
the Muslim woman more than anybody when
Allah has the widget tells you to cover
to protect you right don't be fooled by
what you see and none before but what
you hear Allah has the agility you're so
precious that Allah wants to protect you
it's not me who want to put the hijab on
you it's not your husband who wants to
put the head it's Allah who as you do
you are you working in a supermarket you
work in a restaurant you work in
in in whatever hotel they force you to
to wear a uniform you never have you
ever questioned the place you work why
we have to wear a uniform no you just do
it you just do it you want to make Timon
and I get paid and they are entitled for
it yeah well if you acknowledge that a
la Sol owns this world and he's the
creator of this world why don't you
submit to his order he's the one who
ordered you to cover and if you look at
it from the other angle it's for your
interest there is a video I'm sure you
saw it on YouTube where they show a
woman walking in New York yes
she's like regular American and how many
the guy walked with her for a while yeah
and then they put a cover in her and she
got zero attention how's the respect in
there right away
this is a lunch solution yeah they even
had a sensor that they put you put these
touch sensors on the woman well and then
they measured how many times she got
felt up and grabbing the club
subhanAllah yeah use it I mean a woman
would take actually didn't be in a club
yeah but the idea is but it's sad you
know what it's happening some places
Panama was [ __ ] again that the problem
is we don't appreciate our religion
because again I I bet you I mean this is
I'm 100% sure this woman who ends up in
the places like that she did not find
the true slam in her house mm-hmm she
didn't find the true slam in the message
she attended so she's taking it more as
a culture she doesn't know yeah I meet
Muslims who are 20 in their 20s and 30s
they don't even know it Fatiha and they
said we lost Steve don't even know the
open Fatiha
which is the sore on the first they have
no idea what I say where they were your
parents been said they're busy working
and you sit with the parents say I want
to make a good life good future for my
children there is no good future in the
Hellfire how long they gonna live here
for what
yeah think about but nobody is telling
you not to work hard to provide great
lifestyle for your children but it's how
you sleep when your children are outside
in the night how you sleep when you know
your children don't even know how to
pray yeah you know what kind what's that
what's the taste of any money or any
wealth or any pleasure in this world
when a line is missing you mentioned
that example now they put a job on the
woman and then all of the respect hidden
she got stuck with all the teething and
toss it taunts on that and then what
were you saying from there now back to
this Weinstein and the celebrities and
everybody again it's if you look at the
a lot of these women abused because
they're not Muslims right but if you
look what ELISA Lam's is that a woman
should do and by the way when Islam says
the woman should not be alone with that
strange man it's the same thing for a
man i mentioned a muslim man should not
be with a strange woman who's not
related to him right in the same room
related to him in the sense that he
cannot marry her right
like his aunt his grandmother but he
still he cannot be in a room with his
his cousin because they can get married
so he's not allowed to be alone so it's
not only applied to most of the laws in
this lab apply equally between men and
women there's certain laws only specific
form in certain laws specific or yeah so
the issue of shaking hands shaking hands
is applied to Muslim men and Muslim
women and they come and they tell you or
this is extreme this is too much this is
this this is phonetic
well next guy who gonna hold your hand
and start make you feel uncomfortable
how many I asked those sisters how many
times you shook hands with men that made
you uncomfortable right so so and then
you you argue about it if it's right or
it's wrong Allah has ordered whatever he
said is for the best of you yeah and for
the best of us for your protection a
hundred percent we're not when this
woman with Weinstein
she went to hang out with him he told
her hang out in his bedroom in his hotel
room
if a Muslim father is lamenting Gators
are coming up she knows that it's forget
about anything
she knows even if she trusts him on a
person she knows Allah says it's hello
so hey she she would have protected
herself right so Allah this the
dienophile Islam is a Dean of prevention
and that's where we need to understand
Dean of prevention when Allah talks
about his zina and and fornication he
does not tell us do not commit
fornication he says what in the Quran he
said don't even get close to ya so any
anyways any pants any any behaviors any
acts that could lead to something how
Allah tells us still yeah prevention we
don't have time here to be fixing
problems we are here for a few years we
need to be dedicated focused on our
mission that is to worship Allah to
establish the hate to spread this
beautiful religion to mankind
instead of getting busy fixing our I
committed this major sin and I commend
where there are solutions but we don't
have that luxury of of an open time we
are infinite trained at one point that
comes to mind I'll go on to the next
question is thinking past not only the
Muslim woman reminding them imitating
the example of Mary the mother of Jesus
was she actually from the pictures we
have that obviously is not her but she
was wearing this hijab and many of these
dignitaries people that were high up in
ranks because at queens and princesses
they were actually wearing what the
Muslim yeoman is wearing I remember a
dr. Finklestein he quoted an example in
history when the when the people came to
this country and then they saw the
natives who were half naked and then
they thought them barbaric now because
uncivilized but now he said that look
we're over here
almost naked and we're calling the
Muslim women uncivilized and barbaric so
it seems like how the time to change you
even go back they used to give tickets
in this country call right if you had it
seems like the skirt if it was above the
ink clothes or something you get a
ticket but now it just keep it it's like
I'm thinking when's it gonna stop so it
gets up to the calves it was below the
knee now it's above the knee offering
the essence of fitting in and fashion
yeah right and the woman she's like
pulling down trying to come you know
she's feeling hug
was their nature if nature is acting
here football yeah a natural instinct
and this is not putting a woman down and
put me they don't know any better they
don't know any better
right societal pressure cultural
pressure is raised into it she doesn't
see it yeah she doesn't see it when I
first came to this country in 1995 and
I'll see women interest in crazy stuff
especially here in South Florida with a
lot of Hispanic and it's part of their
culture to show as much as they can
I said where's the brother where's the
Fatherhood jealous foreign but they're
scared also because they think maybe
they speak up everybody's doing and then
you realize that the fact everybody is
doing it it has become so normal right
and you're going to that to the natives
just what 30 40 years ago all you need
to do is just go check pictures of
beaches in in Miami and in the United
States see what people used to it on the
beach compared to today right yeah see
what how women used to dress yeah so
it's it's it's matter of you don't call
evolution as much as its devolution
right or evolution because if you adhere
someone who's god-fearing anyone who
believes in a creator the Creator
commands modesty sure right modesty is
there as part of it someone said it is
the caveman was wearing only a piece of
cloth and as they progressed and became
more civilized they covered more and
more and more yeah so as we are going
away from being dressed more and more to
less and less we're going back to the
Stone here and again it's in if you have
something precious you don't want to
share it with anybody yes you're wearing
this woman who's wearing almost nothing
and walking on the street she has a
purse in her hand and that purse has
stuff that she doesn't want anybody to
see right and when she wants to open it
you might go to the bathroom well your
body is more precious than anything in
there yeah and that's what Islam wants
you Teresa but what I want to respect
you I listen I'm not saying that if
you're not doing her job or you're not
just probably that you're an evil person
but I'm calling for you to be better
than what you are
right and when you recover more I will
respect you more God wants them to
respect you they want to undress you
that's it that's and that's what we
always in if you look at secularism and
the call for morality is a personal
issue modesty is a personal preference
because that's what they say morality is
a modesty is a personal preference and
again morality has modesty has nothing
to do with what you wear has nothing to
it becomes obvious so what they want
from you they want you free in bed
that's it
you hear that they want you for that's
the fact that that's that straight talk
you can straight talk yeah I mean we're
gonna keep beating around the bush day
he wants to undress it once his ah his
eyes and molest me with his eyes men
women we're men and what holds us from
acting like any other men is Alyssa yes
well other than Islam we will be just
like everybody else right al-hamdu love
with muslims and we're telling you what
men want from you yeah they want you for
free that's it you you you get pregnant
he walks out and you're the one stuck
with a baby but the motions to the side
this is out of love and this is when you
really care for people did you share in
this truth you know I I was treating a
patient in my clinic Monday he's maybe
three or four years old so he's waiting
in the operatory
and I'm going from one patient to
another so and his mother sitting with
him so I walk into the into the room to
check him so he looks at his when I said
mom is this dad he asked his mom is this
dad about me yeah and I got situation
through that so she started laughing
said no no baby so that means this kid
doesn't know who he's dead now I wonder
if this woman knows even who her who is
that is but she stuck with him she's the
one suffering his enjoying his life
maybe he's getting another woman
pregnant right but at the end of the day
it's the woman who gonna lose we men we
we walk out and I I have patients who
five and six and seven children and
everybody with a different last name and
this woman not even third who is paying
the price it's you and when you said
that a lot of women is becoming Muslims
because they find their their protection
in listener yes so they want to be
respected for their minds not used just
for their bodies that's and that's what
from the from the industry from you know
the the men exploiting them this is
what's happening right so if you if
you're God conscious no matter what
human being you are I mean god this is
what God loves that modesty